Corea del Sur aplica la ley del talión
el presidente johnso Joel anunció la
creación de una unidad de drones
furtivos de última tecnología para
vigilar las instalaciones de Corea del
Norte luego de que drones norcoreanos
cruzaran la frontera por primera vez en
cinco años
El dron militar de Corea del Norte
invadió nuestro espacio aéreo fue un
incidente que demostró que la
preparación y el entrenamiento de
nuestro ejército ha sido insuficiente a
lo largo de los años y confirmó
claramente que se necesita una
preparación y un entrenamiento más
fuerte
el ejército surcoreano Se disculpó por
no haber derribado los drones a pesar de
haber desplegado aviones de combate y
helicópteros lo que genera
preocupaciones y serias dudas sobre la
red de defensa aérea de seúl en medio de
las amenazas nucleares del Norte
Tengo estos pensamientos aterradores de
Qué pasaría si esos drones estuvieran
cargados con bombas que desencadenarían
una guerra o algo así tal vez dependemos
demasiado del ejército estadounidense y
parece que siempre respondemos un poco
tarde
por inofensivo que parezca el envío de
drones entre los dos países amenaza con
aumentar las tensiones en la Península
coreana en 2017 una nave no tripulada
norcoreana logró capturar imágenes del
sistema antimisiles tad se cree que pion
yang posee miles de unidades de estos
artefactos